[Música]
se aceitar é vital é necessário quando
você não se aceita automaticamente o
resto da frase que eu usei no título
dessa palestra fica meio desfalcado
porque o resto disse e você quando eu
digo você eu pergunto você se aceita e
você você me aceita
bom eu tive o privilégio de nascer no
subúrbio que nasceu no curuzu na senzala
do barro preto curuzu liberdade aqui na
cidade salvador
isso é criado no subúrbio ferroviário
daqui de salvador também mas dentro
desse privilégio que digo que é um
privilégio porque nesse lugar nesses
lugares onde eu nasci onde morei eu tive
o privilégio de acessar de cara a arte
ea arte ela chegou até a mim no momento
muito interessante porque era um momento
em que o momento institucional da
cultura ou seja na escola a escola é o
lugar onde a cultura se apresenta
institucionalmente e isso me ajudou
logo cedo a entender que eu precisava
barrar o processo de fabricação da morte
simbólica e física dos negros e negras
no brasil quando a arte entrou na minha
vida fazia teatro na escola que era
junto com a igreja que era junto com as
pessoas da comunidade que nossas
vizinhas trabalhava todo mundo ali e
quando falo do processo de fabricação da
morte simbólica é porque dentro daquele
bairro
naquele lugar a tudo o que a gente sabia
sobre negritude era negativo
a gente sabe que o processo de
fabricação da morte simbólica do negro e
do negro no brasil ele está presente
desde que o brasil brasil brasil já
nasce corrupto
o brasil já nasce de uma corrupção
dentro dessa corrupção desse nascimento
do brasil desse dna do brasil a gente
pode identificar que
todos os negros que vieram dos países
africanos para cá vieram na condição de
escravos né
foram escravizadas lá eles não era isso
a gente sabe muito bem só que tem uma
situação que é muito muito difícil de
lidar e que até hoje atrapalha a gente
causa barramento na vida da gente que é
o negro que chegou aqui
apesar de ele vê na condição de escravo
usado ele também era colonizador olha
que confusão que confusão você chegar
numa terra que não é sua
sem a sua vontade de vir e ser obrigado
a ser colonizador desde que o brasil é
brasil o processo de fabricação da morte
simbólica da gente e o processo de
fabricação da morte física essa não
preciso explicar muito
ela existe
posso citar aqui pra vocês é quatro
pilares que são importantes na
desconstrução desse processo de
fabricação da morte simbólica física
para que a gente possa se aceitar um dos
fatores é o fator cultural
a gente sabe que desde sempre a cultura
afro-brasileira ela sofre um desde em
ela sofre uma desvalorização na vida da
gente na vida do brasileiro em si
na maioria das vezes ela é assistida de
uma forma depreciativa até um certo
tempo atrás tudo que via do negro era
considerado vadiagem vagabundagem né
a gente conhece eu posso citar um
exemplo aqui se vocês quiserem capoeira
que mais samba que mais funk rap
bastou dar dinheiro virou cultura de
massa
bastou trazer capital atender às
necessidades do capitalismo virou
cultura de massa e nós negros
deixamos de seus vagabundos donos da
cultura o comum é da cultura
o povo para simplesmente apreciadores da
cultura de massa cujos donos cujos
ganhadores cujos monetizá dores são
aqueles que outrora dizia que isso não
prestava que isso era vadiagem passando
para o segundo fator a gente tem um
outro pilar que é a política brasileira
a política brasileira também faz parte
do processo de fabricação simbólica e eu
não preciso ir muito fundo porque se a
gente perguntar se tem negros e negras
na política não tem é engraçado que eu
estava olhando assim a lava jato que a
fãa você não tem medo da lapa já
tradicional não tem negro na política
vai ter nenhum preso na lava jato não
tem a política da gente simbolicamente
não têm negros porque ela entende que
nós não entendemos de política o
cristianismo atua de uma forma aqui que
basta iniciar a eleição ea gente já sabe
quem vai ganhar
e quando eu falo da religiosidade é o
terceiro pilar
eu queria contar uma história que é
muito fácil e vocês a seguir mas já
similar em que o processo de fabricação
simbólica também atinge entrar a atingir
a gente por meio da religiosidade porque
eu comecei a fazer teatro
eu comecei essa arte na escola uma
escola católica como falei no início só
que aos 15 anos de idade
eu comecei acessar a história do brasil
e vi que era contraditório para uma
pessoa como eu negro suburbano pobre
sustentar uma instituição como a igreja
católica que há pouco tempo atrás
legítimo escravidão que há pouco tempo
atrás dizimou milhares de negros
africanos e era a grande culpada de hoje
eu érico brás não ter foto dos meus avós
ele disse se essa instituição que eu
faço parte é responsável por isso é
contraditório no mínimo pra mim tá aqui
eu não faço parte disso eu faço parte de
que fui pesquisar e claro como na bahia
o candomblé é muito fácil eu acessei o
candomblé no candomblé
eu descobri que eu tinha uma energia de
energia que é xangô automaticamente
descobrir que agora requer orixá do fogo
quero deixar da pedreira e é de centro
aprofundando um pouco mais do ponto de
vista social na cidade de salvador na
bahia e no brasil descobrir que a
dinastia de xangô tem doze obás ou seja
12 ministros seis da direita seja da
esquerda
o interessante se eu sou de xangô eu
posso ser um ministro caindo na pesquisa
eu descobrir que a maioria dos ministros
de changle na cidade de salvador eram
brancos hora disse reivindicar no lugar
porque porque se mário cravo dorival
caymmi e jorge amado podiam ser porque
não posso ser
e aí eu já sou um dos ministros de
chapéus ou mobile chan
quando eu faço isso quando o acesso
automaticamente estou barrando o
processo de fabricação 5 de morte um
processo de fabricação da morte
simbólica e física dentro da
religiosidade nota dizendo que a gente
precisa entender o que nós fomos o que
nós somos para conseguirmos projetar
para onde iremos
o quarto pilar é a economia
o processo de fabricação da morte
simbólica do povo preto também está na
cor da economia não só simbólica como
física claro que o primeiro simbólica
porque porque dizem que as não dão
dinheiro pra gente não paga a gente
direito porque a gente não sabe gastar
dinheiro a gente não sabe usar dinheiro
preto não sabe o dinheiro a abra seu
cofre para mim
eu sei o que eu vou fazer
a impressão que dá é que acham que a
gente ainda está no período colonial em
que se trabalhava só para comemorar
isso não é verdade
o projeto o processo de fabricação da
morte simbólica da gente está todo dia
na frente da gente
a publicidade faz isso todo dia com a
gente
por mais que a gente consuma trilhões no
produto interno bruto desse país
a gente tá fora www é impressionante que
o para o processo de fabricação da morte
simbólica eles se distribuem entre a
gente e temos deixado absolutamente
deformados e isso chega na gente há
muito tempo desde que o brasil brasil
mas existe um fenômeno um fenômeno que
aconteceu nos últimos tempos que
facilitou isso muito que é a
globalização a globalização ela traz
consigo capitalismo e traz um meio que é
muito fácil que está na mão de todo
mundo se eu quiser provar tá na mão de
vocês agora que é a internet
a globalização ela abre as fronteiras em
geral todas as fronteiras
isso é muito perigoso porque a gente
perde as nossas referências a gente
perde os valores culturais achando que
nós somos parte de um tudo e não somos
então é perverso dizer que a
globalização ajuda
ela abriu as fronteiras das nossas
culturas a ponto de formar gente
vou dar um exemplo da minha vida em
junho desse ano eu fui na nigéria e eu
reflexo do eurocentrismo instalado no
brasil automaticamente desde a 10 sendo
em lagos
tomei um choque cultural de algo que era
meu
isso é absurdo porque
à noite quando na primeira noite eu
passei lá quando eu acordei de manhã que
eu decida tomar café da manhã eu comigo
se come na feira de são joaquim
isso é meu tá ali eu não imaginava que
era verdade que existe em nenhum outro
lugar
claro que a gente sabe que a herança da
cultura africana
mas você vê em outro lugar
uma vez eu saindo do teatro vila velha
quando ela participava do bando de
teatro olodum eu passei por uma situação
que muito tempo depois quando eu
consegui identificar o processo de
fabricação da morte simbólica e física
dos negros e negras no brasil
eu fui entender o que era isso que eu
tinha acabado de fazer um espetáculo
chamado cabaré da raça sucesso na cidade
não sei se alguém aqui já assistiu e é
engraçado o teatro estava lotado
ingressos esgotados todo mundo gritando
cenas maravilhosas e é de 7 quando o
time terminou o espetáculo eu voltei
para a vida real que era pegar meu uso
ônibus e dezembro suburbano
as pessoas que estavam na platéia também
voltaram à vida real do que o teatro tem
essa função é o teatro traz pra gente um
momento que a gente consegue sair da
vida com um entrar num outro espaço
muito tempo então voltando à vida real
ocorrido em um ponto de ônibus para
pegar o meu ônibus quando cheguei no
ponto de ônibus encontram as pessoas que
sempre pegar esse ônibus comigo era o
último ônibus da noite para ir para os
subúrbios e tem desejo já era só no
outro dia quando faltava mais ou menos
uns 10 minutos para o meu ônibus passar
chegou uma viatura da polícia com três
policiais e uma mulher branca dentro
dizendo foi ele foi ali foi a de ficar
na fila e eu seu que foi ele quem roubou
a minha bolsa de dar meia hora pelo amor
de deus não foi nem foi ele foi foi foi
foi foi foi ele foi no time não foi pro
céu da boca pelo me a moça tirou do jogo
no chão eu disputa não foi ela falou foi
ele foi ele era preto assim ela assim
nessa época tinha 19 mesmo na época dos
jogos grandes da pedra
aí a senhora acabei de sair do teatro
falou 'você artista de soul em você
ardis o cadê sua carteira de ajuda não
tem um campeão de artes da
então você nerd está aí já era enfim ela
disse foi ele disse olha só eu acabei de
sair do teatro de ensaio do teatro ela
prestou atenção lá disse que acha que
você tava de seu time no teatro vila
velha fazer um cadastro não foi ele não
não fui a menina você é você
eu faço aquele personagem lembra o
personagem foi patrocinado parra faz por
aí comecei a dar texto da peça de noé
eu acabei de ver sua peça acabei você é
maravilhoso você é lindo olha a do seu
personagem no seu entender que o é e eu
faço isso eu faço aqui mais um sim eu
sei que comecei da fala é porque tem um
momento que a gente entra no correndo
que nem sequer falo isso maravilhoso
a arte tinha acabado de me salvar mais
uma vez meu ônibus passou o último
olhei para o relógio disse agora
policial de serra já que não foi você
vai conseguir estar liberada ela disse
olha não for ele vamos adiantar porque
ele consegue pegar essa pessoa em
qualquer lugar
o me desculpe meu querido tchau se ele
tá beleza foram só de dar uma pausa de
entrar na polícia nós vamos agora entrar
os três policiais ela entrou também na
viatura bateu à porta
eles levam anos para ir a brasília o
olho já se vira negão de vir aí dormir
no banco do ponto de ônibus até às cinco
da manhã até passar o primeiro ônibus
para o subúrbio
analisando isso depois disse nossa como
ela matou o artista em menos de cinco
minutos e transformou num bandido
olha como ela em questão de segundos
pegou o bandido voltou a ser artista e
pior que isso
ela tinha poder sobre o estado
ela tinha poder de dizer à polícia é
esse não é esse vamos embora porque
ainda vai pegar
olha essa mulher pagou ingresso pra mim
olha essa mulher se divertiu com minha
arte
confesso a vocês que analisando depois
me sentir como os negros que chegavam no
cais no mercado modelo e para não ficar
tanto tempo ali sentado com mercadoria
provavam que estava bom da perna que
está mundo dent isso outro dia agora em
eu estou dizendo que o processo de
fabricação da morte simbólica não deixa
a gente se aceitar que a gente precisa
descobrir meios como descobrir pra
quebrar isso não é fácil não é fácil
seria utópico da minha parte dizer que
vamos acabar com a globalização com o
capitalismo com a internet
precisa disso não tem mais como escapar
mas precisamos aprender a fechar as
fronteiras da gente
e essas fronteiras que parou são as
fronteiras culturais religiosas e
econômicas políticas e escolhendo
pessoas que representem a gente direito
com ideologia com conceito com o corpo
o simbolismo com a atitude de mudança
quando eu digo que me aceito que
perguntar você aí você se aceita porque
eu estou tranquilo estou tranqüilo pra
fechar entendamos que respeito
não é algo que se pede que está na
constituição
errou tem que pagar
a gente está querendo é poder porque o
poder é um poder deixa a gente fazer
permite a gente ser e autoriza a gente
está por isso eu digo eu me aceito e
você
[Música]
[Aplausos]